a moment of panic on a bustling Street
in South London police target a man
suspected of stabbing two people within
minutes he was shot dead armed officers
who were part of a proactive
counterterrorism surveillance operation
and were following the suspect on foot
were in immediate attendance and shot a
male suspect dead at the scene the
suspect had been recently released from
prison where he had been serving a
sentence for Islamist related terrorism
the suspect was wearing a hoax explosive
device this is the first such attack to
happen in a relatively unknown London
suburb and it's shaken the people here
incredibly shocked and absolutely
devastated that this should have
happened and that should happen here in
Stretton we pride ourselves on being an
enclosed inclusive welcoming community
and so many people from so many
different backgrounds living you know
very harmoniously together and it's a
place where you just wouldn't expect
this to happen I think it's it's you
know obviously that was like one street
away from where you live it makes you
feel a bit unsafe because you know if we
had left the house 10 minutes earlier we
would have been here as it was happening
rather than you know just as I had
finished you know it's it makes just
feel yeah not very very safe forensic
teams remain at the scene combing the
area for clues
politicians took to Twitter including
the British prime minister who extended
his sympathy to those affected and
London Mayor Sadiq Khan who said
terrorists seek to divide us and destroy
our way of life here in London we will
never let them succeed this is the
second terrorism related stabbing
incident in London in just over two
months and it's likely to put intense
pressure on Boris Johnson and his
government to do more to prevent such
attacks in the future stencil al Jazeera
London